one of the characteristics of Cults is
consistency doesn't matter the
consistency of the message that you
believe from your cult leader doesn't
matter it can change overnight and you
simply change your thinking and the cult
leader is Justified if they move on to
yes support local police but federal
police has been weaponized as a
political tool against Republicans only
so the FBI and the doj must be defunded
they will just adjust their view the the
double standard doesn't matter the about
face doesn't matter and this is one of
the characteristics of Cults you hear a
from the from the dear leader and you
follow it and the next day the leader
says not a and you say oh we're
following that and their word is perfect
and their word is divine almost like a
pseudo deity